this on your dash
the funnier death
if there's something there
stop eating eggs next to me stop
breathing next to me
so where you working tomorrow same place
same place same job like working at a
parking lot yeah it's fine oh my god
you love it I love it like you love eggs
sick put this on your dash
feet baller what's up what are you doing
here
just want to see what's so special about
this place there's nothing special about
this place yeah how many people usually
Park here I don't know a couple also
like - sure you clear out yeah put that
on your -
it's when is it fifty bucks to park here
since yeah yeah five is fine put that on
your dash you know what this parking lot
to succeed or what I'm a minimum-wage
employee here I don't care this parking
lot succeeds next time just give us a
chance are your stole no come on go home
what do people even do in parking lots
Bay Park drink malt liquor smoke weed
drink hard liquor
no they just Park no there's like 500
square feet in here right parking lot is
like 10,000 square feet wait why does
that matter
yes that'll be $50 miss very funny
well you've been wasting away in that
stool I figure out how to save the
parking lot bananas no a farmers market
one table with some shitty fruit does
not make a farmer's market well I've
been tweeting about it for the last hour
so the other farmers should arrive soon
your farmers even Twitter I've also been
snap chatting like a beast so trust me
the words getting out there no just set
up anywhere this is too much
vendors to use 50 bucks right oh yeah um
why don't you set up next to that girl
yeah chief
man that drought listen I want to talk
about it hey you have to shut this down
shut it down why this is awesome and I
bartered three unripe bananas for these
babies there are too many people here
they keep asking me questions you don't
have to answer their questions you're
just the parking lot attendant and a lot
where nobody can park look they're
taking up all the spaces just go back to
your stool you look great in that polo
did you see a go pass through here I'm
picking up a very dark aura would you
like me to cleanse you hey can you
review my necklace from my Etsy account
no he doesn't actually just have it back
if I reviewed it I would say it's
terrible hey dude I really gotta pee is
there a designated area for that here or
all right well my takeaway from this is
I can just pee anywhere then hey no
peeing in the lot I've already started
I'm sorry oh it's so much P hey I don't
sell this I lose the farm there's no
farm so firm somewhere just cuz you
can't see it this camp does exist
Brittany I'm serious I don't want to
work in a farmers market I want to work
in a parking lot where nobody parks why
would you want that when you can have
all this
there's juice samples and crystals I
don't like juice samples and crystals
okay I don't want any vendors I want
this place back the way it was okay I
was just trying to help help me by
getting this crap out of here
am I the crap am i included in the crap
no you're not the crap this morning I
had a job that I liked and and now you
don't know it's okay Brittany I had to
take matters into my own hands your
negative energy is poisoning all of us
now can I get some of that you know
watching your tear into your sister like
that hurt my feelings
hey hey have something to show you
remember your 12th birthday party I
threw up in the pool from eating too
much ice cream cake I actually threw up
because I was really nervous to be
around all of your older friends I mean
I don't see why you can't swim in a pool
full to throw up anyway it's just
chlorine waters gross throw chunks in
the filter not swimming in the filter
do you think today was worse than that
I don't know I mean my reputation like
among the farmers know
especially Krystal she's really hot
I had a crush on Krystal me too
come on let me show you something I'll
even let you sit on my stool
yeah
Wow you did all this for me
I did it for me holy [ __ ] I'm awesome
you're okay man still mad at me I'd do
anything it's cool okay